but fast the story of the weekend is the
rising tensions in the Middle East after
the u.s. killed a senior Iranian General
in Iraq let's speak to the foreign
secretary ad/da McGrath and he joins us
now from central London I mean many
people this morning will be very
concerned about the possibility of a
full-blown conflict even a war between
the u.s. and Iran was Donald Trump right
to order the killing of soleimani well
first of all I share those concerns
we're looking to deescalate and
stabilize the situation that's something
that we've talked about with our
European and American friends I spoke to
the Iraqi Prime Minister just this
morning the rockie president last night
and I'll be reaching out to the foreign
minister of Iran with that same message
you asked about general Soleimani let's
be very clear he was a regional menace
and we understand the position that the
Americans found themselves in and they
have a right to exercise self-defense
they explained the basis on which that's
done and we're sympathetic to the
situation they found themselves in but
there is a risk with the heightening of
tensions and we now want to see the
de-escalation and the stabilization of
the situation and a war in fact is in no
one's interest the only people that were
gained would be - and the terrorists
that would exploit the vacuum so we'll
be working very hard throughout the
diplomatic network with all of our
partners the u.s. the Europeans and in
the region to get that message across
loud and clear you say that the US has a
right to self-defense but the question
was about whether Donald Trump was right
to order the killing of soleimani was it
well the US will take their own
operational judgment call but they've
got the right of self-defense if you
look at what general Soleimani was doing
he wasn't - he's not some victim in this
scenario he was a regional menace he was
in charge of the Qods force the wing of
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard which is
directing militias and proxies in the
region in Iraq in the Lebanon in Syria
which is destabilizing those countries
trying to get an Iranian advantage and
attacking
Western countries that legitimately
there so we understand the position the
us were in and I don't think we should
be naive about the Iranian Revolutionary
Guard or indeed general Soleimani I
don't think anyone's trying to paint
soleimani it's a good guy in this
scenario but at the same time the risks
of as you put it escalation and what
people are concerned about are you
worried that there could be an
accidental war here well I think we need
to avoid that and we need to deescalate
and stabilize the situation my first
concern the first concern of the Prime
Minister and the government is to make
sure we protect UK citizens forces our
diplomatic missions all of that planning
and preparation is in place we are
working very closely together with our
partners to that effect
and it's it is important and that's why
I was reaching out to the Iraqi Prime
Minister this morning first thing we'll
be talking to other partners today as I
have been since Friday to make sure
we're all clear that de-escalation is
necessary an absolute essential no-one
wants I don't think anyone would benefit
from a war in the Middle East the only
people that would benefit will be the
terrorists and - in particular and so
we'll be working with all of our
partners us European partners and those
in the region to get that message across
and to make sure we do manage things
down and deescalate those tensions you
keep using the word escalation and
Donald Trump this morning or this
weekend has said that the u.s. has
identified 52 Iranian sites that it will
hit if Iran targets Americans or US
assets does that sound like
de-escalation to you I think the
Americans are trying to send a very
clear message to Tehran that they cannot
continue the aggressive menacing
behavior whether it's on the
destabilizing activity that general
Soleimani was in charge of throughout
the region whether it's on the nuclear
front or indeed some of its wider
activities for example on attacking
shipping but aside from that message or
supplementing that message we also need
to be clear the
there is a route through which allows
Iran to come in from out of the
international cold and that that
opportunity is there for them if they do
the right things and so I think yes we
need to contain the nefarious actions of
Iran we also need to de-escalate and
stabilize the situation to make clear
that if after all this time the
leadership in Tehran wish to do the
right thing and accept the overtures
that be made not just from the President
of the United States but also from
President macron to actually engage in
proper diplomacy meaningful diplomacy
that route is also available I think
that's the important message I mean
there were reports today that you're
going to be traveling to Washington next
week to the US next week and talking to
the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo are
you going to have a tough message for
Mike Pompey what are you going to say to
him I'm talking I'm meeting with my
French and German colleagues next week
I'm already been scheduled to go to the
US I'm going to Canada as well we're
reaching out to all of our partners but
look at the Americans we're very close
to them I spoke to Mike Pompeo on Friday
we've been very clear about the need for
de-escalation I know that's something
that the Americans share but do you have
a meeting with what polls we're all so
clear
we're also clear that Iran cannot
continue its nefarious activities
whether it's on destabilizing those
countries in the Middle East we need to
see Iran come back to full compliance
with the jcpoa the nuclear deal and
we're also obviously over the recent
months and over the last year seen
increasingly palling behavior in
relation to dual nationals not just UK
dual nationals but others in Iran
so across all of this range of behavior
we want to see and we share with our
European our American colleagues
partners we want to see Iranian behavior
improve and there is an opportunity if
the leadership in Tehran take it to
actually move from the heightened
tensions to a more positive trap so it
just be really clear do you actually
have a meeting with my component speak
yes okay he told fox news's he told
Flint this bit he told Fox News
yesterday frankly the Europeans haven't
been as helpful as I wish that they
could be the Brits the French the
Germans all need to understand that what
we did what the Americans did saved
lives in Europe as well
have you not been helpful in his view
because you actually think that America
has overstepped the market and said that
I understand the position that the
Americans found themselves in I'm
sympathetic and also not for a second
naive about the role of general
Soleimani all the Qods force or the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard nah I think
I made that clear at the same time we
also need to chart a course through
these tensions deist
deescalate the situation try and
stabilize the situation so that - isn't
the main beneficiary of the the
increasing uncertainty and as well as
wanting to contain the agressive
behavior of the hardliners in Tehran of
which general Soleimani was a
torchbearer we also want to make sure
that there is an alternative positive
track through and that can only happen
if Tehran take positive steps to be a
responsible member of the international
community but it is an important message
that there is a track through this if we
can deescalate the situation so we're
we're on the same page with our American
partners we'll continue to talk to them
and I look forward to being in
Washington having those conversations
with Mike I'm interested to find out
what you're doing to protect British
nationals and British interests in the
region amid this clearly very concerning
situation the embassy there for example
British nationals who may be living in
the region are we sending more troops or
more military support into the Middle
East well I'm not going to comment on
the operational matters but on a whole
range of issues protecting our military
missions protecting our diplomatic
missions not just in Iraq but across the
region we're taking the necessary
measures al you'll have seen in the
media reporting we're making sure that
we protect UK shipping in the Strait of
Hormuz and I've revised the travel
device for air
for Iraq and for some of the other
countries in the region to make sure
that we are always putting the safety of
British citizens and British nationals
first you say that you've revised the
safety advice does that mean that
British nationals in the region are now
more at risk
I think there's been instability and for
some time that's no secret and our
travel advisers have been highlighting
the risks as they were but obviously
there have been heightened tensions with
recent events and we want to make sure
that we're giving very clear and
objective advice and advising against
all but essential travel to Iraq and
Iran are they more at risk now well I
think obviously as the tensions rise we
want to make sure that we're monitoring
the risk very carefully we don't want to
see anyone put it any undue risk or any
risk that we can't forcibly avoid and so
what we're doing and this is not new
it's the the job of government and the
FCO we monitor travel advice right
across the world consistently and
throughout the year and when we keep it
under a few so we're just doing the the
normal practice to make sure that we're
giving British businesses citizens as
well as protecting our missions
diplomatic military all the advice and
clarity that they need when people in
the region they can be really really
worried about the situation and many
people listening will think you're being
quite vague here you're not talking
about what a military support you're
putting into the region you won't
comment on that
you're not saying if people are more or
less at risk I mean our emergency
evacuation plans in place so that people
can get out if they need to look if we
never comment on the operational
measures that we're taking but you can
rest assure and people can rest assured
that we're doing everything we can from
the travel device through protecting our
military and diplomatic missions to keep
people as safe as possible but you're
talking about the Middle East they we're
talking about Iraq even before recent
events there's a instability there there
that there is a focused effort on
countering - encountering terrorist
groups and in that country and indeed
across the Middle East so this is a
unstable region and what we want to make
sure is that we're providing all the
necessary safeguards and precautions
taking the measures keeping them under
review to do the best we can to mitigate
the risk
to our people whether they're ordinary
citizens businesses or traveling to the
region or indeed our diplomatic posts
and military missions to the station
debt the Middle East is in the grips of
what could be its biggest crisis since
the Iraq war and yet we've heard nothing
from the prime minister who's been on a
holiday in the Caribbean
I mean does he just think that now that
he's won his big majority at the
election he can put his feet up the hard
works over no that's not right prime
ministers in charge in fact I've been in
constant contact with him over the
Christmas break on the whole range of
foreign policy issues we were in touch
on Friday in relation to the situation
in Iraq and the whole government is
working very closely together I spoke to
defense secretary last night I talked to
the national security advisor on Friday
and we're very clear on the strategy and
how we're implementing it and he'll be
back in play tomorrow in this get in in
the UK so why isn't me seven thing all
come back from holiday couple days early
well he's in charge as I said we've been
in regular contact over the Christmas
break and what's what really matters
here is that the government has got a
very clear strategy and message which is
that we want to see de-escalation we're
going to do everything we can to protect
UK diplomatic military missions and
we're going about that business and I've
been hitting the phone's hard in
relation to all of our international
partners and as you said I'll be
traveling and meeting with our European
partners our American friends are be in
Montreal meeting my Canadian opposite
number as well and so the diplomatic
effort goes on and indeed the Prime
Minister has been engaged in that as
well the husband of nuzzling has a guy
arackliffe calls in prison in Iran who
said that he's worried about her safety
in the wake of what's happening and
there were reports in the papers today
that she's worried about being kept in
jail longer as a result what assurances
are you seeking about her safety
that's one of the issues in relation to
run that's at the forefront of my mind
we have seen intransigence from the
regime in relation to all of our dual
nationals I think they've been subject
to appalling treatment as the dual
nationals of other countries have so
that is part of the nefarious behavior
that we've seen from the hardliners in
Iran they have not complied with our
obligations under international law
they're not being responsible members of
the international community and that
follows through and it's a pattern of
behavior which tracks from their
flouting of the obligations to not to
pursue a nuclear weapon II it's clearly
relevant to the destabilizing activities
that general Soleimani was responsible
for but also it relates to their
increasingly callous and cold treatment
of dual nationals and that must end
immediately we want to see all our dual
nationals brought home as soon as
possible and the truth is that Iran has
an opportunity amidst all the heightened
tensions it has a choice to make
and it can continue to flout
international or it can continue to
refuse to engage with the diplomatic
initiatives that President Mac corn and
president Trump laid out and and offered
in which case its economic and political
isolation will only grow or it can take
positive steps to rebuild trust and one
of the crucial measures in that regard
would be to release our dual nationals
and to make sure they're being treated
properly okay now there is another case
I'm quite keen to talk to you about
while we have you and that's about the
British teenager in Cyprus who was
convicted of apparently lying about
being gang-raped by 12 Israeli men now
it's something that you said you have
serious concerns about so many people
will share those concerns listen to this
program so what are you going to do
about it
look it's a terrible case and my
feelings of my concerns of the welfare
of that young lady and to make sure that
we can see her come home safe and sound
to the UK and be able to recover and I
have conveyed our concerns about her
treatment and the case to my Cypriot
opposite number and I did that on Friday
I've also spoken to the young lady's
mother to see what more support we can
provide to her so we also need to be
careful that we don't do anything which
aggravates the situation between now and
the date of sentencing which is on
Tuesday but the concerns that we have
and that I have have been squarely and
firmly and categorically registered with
the Cypriot authorities I mean if you
look into this and you feel that there
has been a miscarriage of justice done
on a vulnerable 19 year old when we've
the reports and the papers about
bruising on her body that she's a
potential suicide risk and she's just 19
years old what options are on the table
well as I said
I've reached out to the mother of this
young lady to see what photos of what we
can do to provide her we don't control
the cypriot justice system that's and
they're very sensitive in Cyprus about a
perceived political interference that
there are clear questions around the due
process and the fair trial safeguards
that have applied in this case I've
raised those with my Cypriot opposite
number and we will continue to talk
about that but ultimately my first
priority
I think the first priority the family
will be to see this young lady released
come home safe and sound to this country
to now how to recover so that's what
we're doing and we obviously need to
handle this case very sensitively to
make sure we don't do anything
counterproductive okay and just finally
we're going to be talking to you law
Berkeley later on the program the former
deputy chair of the government's review
into the high-speed Rail Link hs2 is the
government still committed to building
HST yes the promise has made it clear
and we've got a review underway we want
to look at the best way to get value for
money in relation to that substantial
investment we also want to make sure
that we've got the best benefit from it
in terms of the connectivity not just
north-south but in relation to east-west
in the northern region so that's the
point of the review it's underway I
don't want to prejudice the outcome of
it and but we look forward to getting
that review to make sure that we can
really boost connectivity both between
the south and the north but also across
the Midlands and the northern towns and
cities to make sure that we can
rebalance the economy boost economic
growth and make sure that we level up
the opportunities economic and otherwise
in this country